.
YOU PROBABLY NEED MORE.
GRIFF, THANKS VERY MUCH.
LET'S CHRIS OLIVARES IS ON THE
FRONT LINE.
WE TALK ABOUT THESE
DEVELOPMENTS.
I WAS THINKING THE FACT THAT
MORE DEMOCRATS ARE SPEAKING OUT
ABOUT THIS, THAT MIGHT OFFER
SOME HOPE FOR YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, NEIL, I THINK WE
REACHED THAT BREAKING POINT.
WE REACHED IT EVER SINCE LAST
YEAR.
NOW WE'RE SEEING MORE POLITICAL
FIGURES COMING FORWARD AND
VOICING CONCERNS THAT ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
IT IS.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE WHAT IS TAKING
PLACE SINCE LAST YEAR.
GOING TO THE FISCAL YEAR NOW, WE
STILL SEE LARGE GROUPS COMING
ACROS
ACROSS.
THESE PEOPLE WANT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE ACTION.
THEY HAVE NEGLECTED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE THAT RESIDE HERE,
THEY HAVE TURNED THEIR BACKS ON
THEM.
THEY FEEL ABANDONED.
THAT'S WHY THE STATE OF TEXAS IS
FILLING IN THE GAPS WHERE
FEDERAL AGENTS ARE TIED UP
PROCESSING BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE SUPPORT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE, NEIL.
BUT WE'LL CONTINUE SEEING THIS
MASS MIGRATION TAKE PLACE
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
UNTIL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PUTS SOME ACTION IN PLACE, UNTIL
THEY ADDRESS AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A CRISIS ON
THE BORDER.
>> Neil: AND WE STOPPED
ADJUDICATING THESE CASES IN
MEXICO.
NOW THEY'RE DEALT WITH HERE AND
THEY'RE ASYLUM CASES, WHICH
ACCOUNT FOR EIGHT OUT OF THE TEN
MIGRANTS THAT MAKE THEIR WAY
HERE.
ASYLUM SEEMS TO BE THE CARD BY
WHICH THEY TRY TO GET NOT ONLY
TO GET ACCESS TO THE UNITED
STATES, BUT IN THEIR EYES STAY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT THE
ASYLUM CLAIM IS BEING ABUSED.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
CIRCUMVENTING THE PROCESS BY
CLAIM AGO SOIL LUMP WHEN THEY
REACH THE BORDER.
THE FACT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ALLOWED THAT, AN
OPEN BORDER POLICY, THAT'S WHY
WE SEE LARGE GROUPS COMING
ACROSS.
THEY WILL CONTINUE COMING ACROSS
AS LONG AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS AN OPEN BORDER
POLICY AND THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
BUSSING AND FLYING THE
IMMIGRANTS TO THEIR DESTINATION.
THAT'S THE ISSUE THERE.
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY WAS
AN EFFECTIVE TOOL.
WHAT IT DID, SLOWED DOWN MASS
MIGRATION.
IT WOULD KEEP THE IMMIGRANTS
SEEKING ASYLUM, KEEP THEM IN
MEXICO HEAR THEIR CASES.
THERE WAS A MORE CONTROLLED
SITUATION.
RIGHT NOW IT'S OUT OF CONTROL.
I SAY THAT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
1,500 TO 2,000 IMMIGRANTS COME
ACROSS A DAY.
THAT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE.
THAT'S WHY THERE NEEDS TO BE A
MORE EFFECTIVE POLICY IN PLACE
TO HELP SLOW DOWN THE MASS
MIGRATION THAT WE'RE SEEING ON
THE BORDER COMMUNITIES.
>> Neil: ONCE THEY GET OVER AND
WITH THAT ASYLUM CLAIM, THERE'S
A LEGAL PROCESS THAT FACILITATES
THAT FOR YEARS TO COME.
CHRIS, THANK YOU.
FINISH THAT THOUGHT.
>> NO, I WAS GOING TO SAY, YOU
CAN'T BLAME THE IMMIGRANTS FOR
MAKING THE JOURNEY.
THEY'RE BEING ENCOURAGED.
THEY'LL CONTINUE COMING BECAUSE
THEY SEE FRIENDS AND FAMILIES
THAT HAVE MADE THE JOURNEY AND
BEEN RELEASED IN TO THE COUNTRY.
THEY'LL CONTINUE DOING SO UNTIL
THER